i first made my millions of dollars the
first time i ever became a millionaire
was with webcam studio oh really
yeah this is how i first ever made money
i mean i was a kickboxing world champion
but kickboxing's not boxing right yeah
so i'd make like a hundred thousand
dollars a fight you fight two or three
times a year you pay 20 to your manager
you pay taxes but you're not rich rich
you get like 30 to 40 of the money yeah
and and i didn't consider myself rich
like 30 40 grand chunks twice a year
maybe three times a year living in
london london rents need a car
you're trying you know like you're not
rich in any way and that's actually the
reason i retired because i woke up one
day
and i thought i'm giving six hours a day
of absolute focus and energy to this
and i believe i'm smart enough that if i
put that much tenacity into something
else i can be a multi-millionaire i
truly believed that i was like i've
realized now i've reached the pinnacle
of kickboxing my choice is either to
change over to mma
which i was offered to do earlier in my
career but at the time the kickboxing
contract paid more money i had to pay
the bills so i want kickboxing turns
over to mma learn to wrestle change over
to ufc blah blah but this is also like
seven eight years ago where even the ufc
didn't pay the money it pays now
but the ufc still doesn't pay that much
money from what i understand no if
you're like top five or champion yeah
but most of the dudes you're going to
see there on the prelims they're getting
10 grand to fight nine grand to fight
it's not it's nothing right
so it'd be like starting my career all
over again and at the age of 28 i
thought i don't have the gumption to
start again i i've done i've been
through hell for this i've broken my
hand eight times my ribs have been
broken
you know i don't want to do this all
over again so so what do you do when you
realize that hey maybe i don't want to
keep fighting
i really i decide to get rich rich
what does that mean to you when you say
when you're sitting there you're getting
you know 30 40 000 kind of net on a per
flight basis is rich to you like hey i
want a couple hundred thousand dollars a
million bucks 20 million dollars a
billion dollars i want 30 or 40 000
every month 30 or 40 000 every month
about half a million bucks a year give
or take okay if i had that much money i
could do whatever i wanted okay that's
what i decided so what's step one that
you do so step one is maybe that's how
we ended up here together my friend step
one is i decided to be very logical
about it chess player right so i was
like i want money
what is money
how do banks work how does credit work
what's fractional reserve banking all
these things we now know to be the
biggest columns of the century right so
i'm sitting there
researching money for days and days and
days and then i get more mad because i'm
like whoa whoa money's trash and i don't
have any no i'm really now i'm really
annoyed right i thought i thought like
everyone else did that you know everyone
puts their money in the bank and the
money the bank takes some of other
people's money and lends it out i didn't
know they invented it from the sky i
still i still at that point thought
money was linked to gold i didn't know
nothing
so i'm learning all this stuff and i'm
getting really angry i'm like now this
is really annoying me
so um anyway i had a piece of paper
there and i'm in my research phase and
it started to start writing down
some dude on youtube i don't know who he
was some dork he was a pro gold guy this
is before i made bitcoin was probably
around then but like early he was a pro
gold guy saying buy gold buy gold buy
gold and uh he was saying the difference
between an asset a liability et cetera
et cetera so i started trying to write
down what i had it's like i have an
apartment i have a bmw i can i'm in good
shape but i already use that for
fighting uh you know what can i do i can
play chess i'm just writing down the
things i have and what i'm good at and
then i kind of realized i was like i've
got like eight girlfriends
but because because i was traveling the
world and if you win you get ring girl
it's kind of like just she's banging the
winner right you win a world title you
get to choose the ring girl you want
it's pretty easy right so i had a
girlfriend in slovakia i had a
girlfriend in france i had a girlfriend
in england girlfriend all these
girlfriends do they know about each
other no okay but they find out pretty
soon
so um
i had all these girlfriends so i'm like
maybe i could open a strip club and like
be a pimp you know be a gangster about
it
and then that opening strip club that's
absolutely the first thing you thought
about was
well i thought i have these beautiful
girls how can i this is before like
twitch existed so i was like what can i
do with these hot girls it's like it's
just an asset right there's these girls
and a lot of them were messaging me they
thought i was this millionaire world
champion they all wanted to come london
live with me and thought i was a big boy
millionaire and all this stuff so it's
like they they do social media well
partially because that and also because
they met me i turn up i fight i win i
win the world title i leave we're
texting each other they don't they
assume i'm this big boy right
so i'm kind of like what am i going to
do what am i going to do
i thought man i investigated strip clubs
way too much money but this this asset
class of beautiful women was kind of on
my mind for a few days and then by
absolute coincidence i stumbled upon
somewhere on the internet i was on some
one of those websites we used to
download like free games and [ __ ]
from and in the corner somewhere it said
hot girls want to talk to you now or
something i said hot girls i clicked on
that not because i was interested but
because i thought i have hot girls and
it was one of those webcam websites and
i was like ah
so these girls sit here and talk to
dudes for money so i'm gonna get my
girls and they're uh naked they're just
talking how does it work it's 50 50. i
mean it depends on the girl depends what
she wants to do but the the the majority
of the job is not based around being
naked the majority of the job is based
on being entertaining and being uh easy
to talk to and the guys who are talking
to you need to find you uh that you need
to remember their name remember their
dog's name you have to be smart you
can't just be a girl and be a bimbo
naked and make money you have to be
really smart charming interesting happy
all the time positive
and i thought i'm going to try this so i
messaged all five of my girlfriends told
them i had a job for them explained them
what i was going to do i was going to
launch this company four of them agreed
all four flew in sat them around the
same table they were all like who's she
who she who's she i'm like well you're
all my girlfriends two more left
and then uh two stayed and that was the
beginning of my little uh attempt at a
webcam empire and i put the girls there
and
and my role in it all
was i did all the tech side of stuff
which is the first thing of course and
then also
and i get called a pimple law but i and
the reason i use the term is because i
don't see it as a negative term i see it
as positively inspirational and
motivating person i was i'd motivate the
girls i'd make sure they did their job
properly if they had a bad day online
i'd come up with a good excuse for them
oh it's been a football game it's been
really busy don't worry you're so
beautiful don't be upset you did better
than her she did the best today did i
keep everything organized put the
schedules together all that kind of
stuff
and uh is it hard
it's hard because women have to want to
work for you
women have to want to obey you that's
hard and you don't do that this is one
of the biggest misconceptions i really
want to clear this up people in the
movies and stuff pimps are like
aggressive mean men complete opposite
pimps are more like james bond james
bond's a pimp he sleeps with a girl to
get information he doesn't care about
her he is absolutely not really a pimp
he doesn't hit her he makes her love him
she does what he wants he uses sex as a
weapon to reward her and then he
disappears that james bond is absolutely
not really a pimp so i say pimp because
everyone calls me a pimp online trust us
go ha ha you're a pimple they're gonna
get offended it's like no beautiful
women wanted to work for me and they
wanted to work for me because i
displayed supreme supreme competence and
they knew they worked for me they'd make
a lot of money so whenever i was out i'd
meet a waitress and say well you're look
you're working 10 hours a day for
pennies you can work 10 hours a day for
me make 10 grand a month 20 grand a
month and over time i'd just build up
this big this big little
empire of webcam girls and one one point
i had four locations 75 girls working
for me and also when we say locations
like
explain what goes into a location i just
rent houses all right so you rent a
house and in the house you just
literally hey go live here there's like
technology set up and then you can
basically uh just sit in front of the
computer and literally be on the other
end of one of these webcams and guys are
paying by the minute by the hour or
whatever yeah to talk to you uh it's
their choice whether they are doing it
fully clothed just talking getting naked
whatever and then you're taking some cut
of it yeah basically so i had girls who
would live in the house and that was
pretty impressive i just broke down the
web campus you don't know you nailed it
no background information yeah you
nailed it you nailed it you nailed it so
they the girls who lived in the house
would have set them out of hours they
want to do and then we'd have rooms that
they could book in and do x amount of
hours a girl could come and do one a
week or whatever we'd have rooms they
could share
and then um yeah very much exactly like
you said they'd go online they'd do
their hours they'd have their regular
customers they'd get their money and
then i'd take around half of the money
around 50 50 around 50 okay is that high
or low compared to the rest of these
well i'll tell you why it's very low
it's low because
every time a girl would quit and try and
do it by herself she'd make a fraction
of the money overall because she hasn't
got the instruction she hasn't got the
motivation she's just lazy with it right
and women have a very different
mentality to money than men if you show
a woman how to make a thousand dollars
in an hour she'll think i only have to i
only have to work an hour a week whereas
if you show a man how to make a thousand
dollars an hour he thinks i can make 18
000 votes a day
that's the difference between us so if i
had a girl working for me making 20 000
she got 10 i got 10. if she quit she'd
make three for herself if that